All right. Thanks to uh Gotti and
everyone for having me here today.
So uh
I wanted to uh do a few different things
with this talk. I started off wanting to
talk about my personal AI stack and uh I
started thinking everyone has one
because I submitted this uh months ago,
right? And I'm like, well, everyone has
an AI stack, so I probably just want to
talk about some ideas instead.
And uh, Gotti ended up saying, hey,
look, um, you know, it is the name of
the talk. Go ahead and do that instead.
So, I think I'm going to do a
combination of the two. Um, this is the
first one I want to talk about, which is
companies become APIs.
So, Excaladraw, they released a thing.
They're like, "Hey, you can now just
talk to your Excaladraw and it will
produce the entire diagram for you." And
I was like, "Oh, that's pretty cool."
And they're and I'm like, "Okay, what
are the instructions?" And I was looking
for the agentic part. And they came back
and they said, "It's easy. You just log
into Excalibur and you go into the tool
and you type what you want to happen and
the diagram will show up." And as of
like two months ago, that is a
non-starter for me. I I can't like I'm
not going to go to any physical tool and
actually use it. So yeah, that that is
pretty much a non-starter for me. I I
think the way this is heading is your
company exists as an API and if people's
AIs can't use your company in that way,
you kind of don't exist. And I think the
way that is heading is towards
essentially kind of like um IMDb or
Rotten Tomatoes where you have ratings
of software and they're all rated across
lots of different dimensions and your AI
will essentially go out and figure out
um what is the best service for this
particular use case when you ask for
something. And and that's that's
essentially where I think this is going.
So that kind of relates to this one
which is I'm sure everyone is seeing
this uh custom everything. So
a big part of the previous idea is
basically agents are doing more and more
for us instead of us interacting with
the world. We're interacting with our
agents. Our agents are interacting with
the APIs.
So they'll filter our news. They'll
create custom software for us. And
they'll do all all sorts of this stuff
on our behalf.
And uh a big part of that is, you know,
is it starts to separate what we see,
right? And not only different software,
which is kind of crazy. You go into an
environment to do a security test, uh
you might actually find uh completely
custom software. So you you might have
to spin up a completely custom stack to
do the assessment. Um, the other way
this is kind of strange is when you
think about that if everyone has their
own AI filtering their interface to the
world, they're actually getting
different news and different ideas.
They're actually filtering reality into
them and everyone's agent is doing that
for their person. So, it starts to get
into a situation where it's like
everyone's experiencing a different
reality. Like, so you might go to your
next door neighbor who literally lives
next door and be like, "Hey, did you see
this new K-pop video? It's the best
thing ever. I've watched it 95 times.
I've cried every single time I watched
it." And what do you think? Did Did you
see it? And they're like, "You still
believe in Korea?
That's that's not real. It's it's like
the moon. It's not real." So, I think we
could just be so separated into our own
little worlds, which which will be
really weird.
This next one is uh companies becoming a
graph of algorithms.
So this comes from my experience doing a
whole lot of consulting and being inside
of a lot of companies over a couple
decades. And the thing that I've kind of
realized is most companies are just kind
of winging it. There are many companies
who aren't right like big banks, big
energy, military type places. They tend
to have a lot of processes but in
general it's usually humans doing all
these pieces.
and the the recommendation, the
documents, the processes, they're more
of like recommendations than actual
rules.
And I think that's going to switch into
something like this because I think this
is what CEOs and CFOs are actually going
to want. They're going to want to see
their company like this and AI
definitely wants to see your company
like this. Otherwise, it can't
understand it to be able to change it.
So, I I think this is a a big push
that's going to come from the top down.
So, this next one is kind of like the
last one, but actually bigger and
crazier. And it's the idea that
companies move from being human to being
process. And I I don't mean AI run,
which which is also true, but I'm
talking about specifically about
processes. So, I was embedded inside of
a a large energy company for a very long
time and I learned something extremely
crazy there. Uh, when something bad
happens, they don't ask who did it and
like they're about to get in trouble.
They only have one question. Did we
follow the process?
And if the process was followed, they're
like, "Okay, cool. That's fine. let's
find out what the problem was and let's
get a whole bunch of meetings together
and we'll make that slight little tweak
to the process and now that's the new
process and everyone follows it or you
get fired and so that that tweak I think
is about to come to everyone right so
this will be a matter of AI then being
able to see all those SOPs and keep them
updated
and one thing I find really interesting
about this is actually what it looks for
security,
right? So security, we've had this
problem of like we've always wanted to
move left, right? We've always wanted to
move left in the process, but what if
you could just build software correctly
the first time using an SOP? Now, of
course, everyone's been saying that
forever, but
I'm reminded that if you go to like a
skyscraper site where they're building a
skyscraper, there's no like place that
you go and you're like, "Hey, who's
responsible for this building?" and not
falling down.
There's no such person. There's no such
department. It's literally built into
every part of the plan and they just
follow that plan. Now, we've been trying
this with humans. It hasn't worked out
well. But I think the big change here is
now people aren't really writing code
themselves. The AI is already writing
all the code, so why can't it be given a
solid SOP to write against? So I think
that's uh kind of where things are
heading.
All right. So now I want to talk a
little bit about the stack that I use.
Um so these are some of the main ideas.
So I I like to have one single unified
AI system and anything I do inside of AI
I bring into it. If I learn something
from some other AI, I bring that in as a
module. And the centerpiece is to have
the human the person at the center. And
it doesn't have to be like a super nerd
like us, right? It could be an artist,
an entrepreneur,
uh a philosopher, whoever it is. And the
goal of this whole system is to kind of
amplify and magnify humans. So it's to
focus on your capabilities and what can
make you stronger.
So the way that materializes is
basically putting people at the center
as opposed to so mine is cloud codebased
but code is not the center of it. It's
more so the magnification of the human
and essentially yeah trying to give
everyone that advantage
>> here.
>> All right so I don't think we have audio
>> upgrade skill. So this is the PI upgrade
skill that's part of the platform. And
what this does, I'm sure everyone in
here has anxiety even just watching this
talk. You're thinking, you're thinking,
I should be actually using AI right now
and I'm getting behind just by being at
this conference. this pi upgrade skill
what it does is it it looks at every
single engineering blog from anthropic
also openai uh I think maybe a couple of
others mo mostly anthropic though and uh
it basically goes and finds all
everything they've said
everything they've said about what
should be upgraded
>> um like new releases it looks at all
their GitHub um releases it looks at
their release notes for the current
release um actually has a time stamp
from the last time we checked. So all
previous releases since we looked the
last time [snorts] and it consolidates
all of that but then it looks at my
existing system and all the changes that
we've made and all the goals and skills
and everything and then it matches up
what it thinks would be best for us to
upgrade so I don't have to track all
that which is highly uh highly
stressful.
So this is uh some of the sources that
it goes after and this is what the
output kind of looks like. Comes back
with recommendations on we should change
this skill, we should update this skill,
we should add agents, whatever.
All right, this one is really cool. This
one is called council.
So this one actually spins up based on
the task that you give it. It spins up
like between two and 16 custom agents
who are experts in that field and they
fight.
They debate aggressively
on which direction it should go. And the
main agent watches them fight, watches
the debate. And I one of the parameters
is how many rounds you want it to go
for. So they debate back and forth.
um basically communicating like no it
should go we should go with this
test-driven development platform or spec
driven development or whatever it is. So
this is what that looks like when they
come back. They form their opinions.
They make their best argument and then
the parent uh agent basically says okay
we're going to go this direction or
actually currently it makes that
recommendation to me and then I choose
which one
and that's some more of the output.
Uh this one is first principles.
This one just basically reverse
engineers um exactly what the root cause
can be instead of like troubleshooting a
specific cause. So we won't go into that
one. Iterative depth. This one is it's
it's a research uh paper that came out
that basically says if you ask the same
question from a different perspective
over and over, the AI gets extremely
smart. It gets way smarter than it
should have. um just because it's
hearing the same question but in a
slightly different way. So it's hitting
the same sort of idea surface but it's
covering it more thoroughly and I've had
really good results with it.
This one is really cool. It also comes
from a paper uh by Zang uh and and the
crew over there and basically what it
does is it creates wildly more creative
results than just uh doing something
like changing temperature or something
like that. uh what it does is it's um
it's just messing with the probabilities
for the output that it chooses and it's
uh also quite effective especially when
you're trying to think out of the box.
All right, so this one is the absolute
craziest one. This is the probably the
most interesting uh piece of the whole
pi ecosystem and this is the algorithm
and the idea is that I'm trying to
pursue and keep in mind for all the
academics here this is highly
theoretical and uh it's experimental
okay but I found that it works but I
know how hard the problem is and I'm not
underestimating it the idea is software
is moving so fast with AI Because it has
handholds, it's able to grab onto
something which is does it work or does
it not work? Well, what are you going to
do if you say write me an essay about
mindbody transfer in Arkansas in 2038
or write me a short story? How does it
know what a good short story is? So what
the system does is it attempts to build
an ideal state for any scenario not just
coding but any general scenario. So what
what it's actually building is a set of
um criteria
that that it can use for handholds and
the ideal state criteria are the same
exact ones as the verification criteria
and it's produced some absolutely insane
results. So this is what it looks like
when it reverse engineers a request. So
keep in mind it knows everything about
me. So I could give a single sentence
and it can say well he probably meant
this because of all this context and
then it breaks apart this is what he
definitely didn't want this is what he
definitely did want and it turns those
all into discrete testable
ideal state criteria and puts them
inside the uh cloud code task system. So
it's being maintained by cloud code.
And this is some more of the output.
And this is what it looks like. So when
I run this thing, I could actually see
tons of uh
engagements. Basically, all the
different agents that I have working on
things. I could see where they are
inside of the algorithm and how far
they're proceeding.
All right. So this one here I haven't
talked about before at all. This one is
uh called Arbull, which is Spanish for
tree. And I've been trying to do this
for like 10 years, and I was just doing
it with like CLI stuff. And what this
actually is is it's a it's a discrete
AI or any type of functionality. You
could put it into a single little
container, a single little action. That
action can run locally on a command
line. It can run in the cloud. I'm
specifically using Cloudflare workers.
And you can then chain any action into
any other action. You can combine them
into a pipeline. And if you connect it
to a source and an output, it becomes a
flow. So I could run a command line to,
for example, go find all the top level
domains for Tesla and then pipe that
into get subdomains and pipe that into
Naboo and get the ports. So, these are
all independently discreet and I have
like
a whole bunch of these.
Yeah, I've got tons of them and I I just
I use them to build things. So, this is
an example of something I built with it.
Uh this is called uh surface uh a thing
I built for myself and what this does is
it takes all my 4,000 different
um sources. So, I've got like Intel
sources, OSENT people, uh YouTube
videos, mostly RSS, uh Blue Sky people,
and basically take um all of their
sources, process it through, and then I
have a thing called label and rate, and
it rates the quality of this content um
and then it puts it into this interface
for me, sorted with labels and
everything. So, what this means is if
Mark Andre
writes a shitty essay,
it will not show up. And if a
nine-year-old kid from Idaho in whatever
I don't know what grade that is, fourth
grade, I don't know, whatever grade
they're in, they write an essay and it's
amazing,
it will show up. So, it's like it's it's
basically uh democratized the whole the
whole quality thing. Um, so you can find
the best stuff. So just a use case for
all the different uh arbo pieces
together.
All right. Yeah. So I would say the main
takeaways for this are you want to make
anything that you're doing
you want to have it be clear in your
mind. You do not want to have anything
that you care about be like an amorphous
sort of blob because I feel like that is
an attack point for somebody in AI,
somebody some McKenzie, a a giant team
of smiling 22 year olds to come and
attack that thing and extract everything
out of it and basically um turn that
into a process which basically
outsources you. Right? So the idea is we
should get there first. Right? The other
idea, main takeaway here is when you
have a unified AI system like this,
you can basically take everything you're
doing and put it inside the system. You
put your context in here, you put all
your tools, like all those different
tools that I ran, um, the PI upgrade
skill, they're all available to the
algorithm. The algorithm instantly knows
how to use anything custom that I built.
So what that means is you end up only
doing anything once and then you
incorporate it into your harness and
then it's just part of your system. And
I I think this is the way to go. I I
think enterprises are moving in this
direction and I unfortunately people
like McKenzie are moving in this
direction as well. And I think we want
to get there before they do. Basically
this is the project. It's called uh PI
personal AI infrastructure. It's an open
source project and just had a release
and I definitely recommend you check it
out
and thanks for your time.
Questions for Daniel.
>> All right, one over there
about two three minutes of questions.
Hello. Um, I'm very interested in that
algorithm, the climbing. Um, do your
agents, um, draw inspiration from
something like gradient descent? Could
it be like, uh, you know, are they
converging at something? So, can you
give us a little more uh about that?
>> No, I think based on that question,
you'll be horribly disappointed. Um, no.
It it's more so along the lines of just
imagining all the things that I probably
meant when I when I made this request.
So, if I say, "Hey, build me an entire
role playing game system. I want
history, languages, terrain, combat
system, all that kind of stuff."
I think what we don't realize is we're
it's called writer's blindness where you
have something in your mind but you're
not communicating it clearly. And I
think this is like a central theme for
all AI. Clarity of thought, clarity of
articulation is like absolutely
everything. So what I'm trying to do is
have the algorithm reverse that and pull
that out. So it's looking at my context.
It's turning those into ideal state
criteria. And the the strict rule is it
has to be discreet and testable because
when we get all the way there's seven
phases of the algorithm which is roughly
oh I should have mentioned that the
algorithm is roughly based on the
scientific method. So it it goes through
like you have experiments you have the
testing and the verification is at the
very end and that ideal state criteria
is what you use for the verification.
So, real quick, real quick question. Um,
as all of this continues to grow, you
all have your own personal AI systems,
things like that. Do you think we'll
ever get to a point where enterprises
adopt uh bring your own AI, bring your
own AI assistant?
>> Um, I think they already are right now
just out of a panic. Um, because all all
their management is telling them you
must do this immediately. Um, I I think
this is the way to go. Obviously,
they're going to have guardrails for
that. But, um, I mean, this is built on
top of cloud code, right? Guess what it
is? It's Markdown just like cloud code,
which means everyone's allowed to use
cloud code at work anyway. So, you just
you can just like put this on top and
you're good to go. It's just context
that and skills that are adding that are
bringing this.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I love K-pop. Who doesn't, right?
Um I was wondering how much money you
actually spent on this project of stock.
It's a lot of uh you know work there.
>> Uh not as much as if I didn't have the
subscriptions. Uh yeah, you you get the
uh Mac subscription and you have
theoretically maybe more than one
account. And yeah, that's pretty much
it. I think I think I need to go.
Thanks. I'll I'll be around if you want
to chat.
Um, before Daniel goes, thank you very
much.
>> I want to say a couple words about
Daniel. So, um,
I think a lot of us try to keep up. I
mentioned it earlier, other people
mentioned it across the day, but how we
try to keep up, how we have to be our
own researchers, how do we have to build
our own tooling all the time. And my
bets aside on vibe coding, like vibe
ops, DevOps kind of thing happening for
teams. when any of us in this industry
want to learn about what others are
doing or not to do all the research on
our own, we go to Daniel. And Daniel
really felt awkward about coming on
stage and showing you scaffolding and
things you're probably doing on your
own, which would be relevant in three
months because everything would move on.
But he's the literally in the in the
committee when we went through the CFP
process, Daniel didn't really have time
to submit a lot. And he's not one of
these superstars who just put in a
couple of words and be done with it.
usually puts in a lot of effort and we
automatically were about to just we
didn't know who was submitting what we
said this really interesting but this
doesn't put in a lot of there's not a
lot of effort here right ask the please
ask this presenter to give us more
because we want to approve this and Greg
Notch who is here out there take instead
of being in the room just allow going
through tickets and doing volunteering
work said I would accept this talk only
if it's from Daniel not know it was
actually him so I really appreciate you
coming on stage anyway and showing all
thank